Let's say in the distributed system, there are two events. I don't
know where they are happening. There's an event called a and there's
an event called b. Somewhere in the distributed system, these two events
are happening. And it so happens, when I look at the record
of all the time stamp associated with the events, I see that
the time stamp associated with a is less than the time stamp
associated with b. So I want to make sure that you understand
the premise of the problem here. What I am saying is that the
time stamp that is associated with the event a happens
to be less than time stamp associated with the event
b. That's what I am observing, by looking at sort
of a log record of all the events that took
place in the system and now my question to you is. If C of a is less than C of
b, does that mean that a happened before b or
does it mean b happened before a or does it mean
a happened before b with the condition that it's either the case that
a and b are events in the same process or a is the
act of sending a message and b is the act of receiving the
corresponding message. So you have to pick
the right choice among these three choices.